another way to overcome AI fatigue is really
really understanding specific task for specific AI
this is very important AI have their strength
at the same time you also have what you wanna do
you need to be able to tell specifically
what you want AI to do for you
at every point in time for example
when do you need to generate boilerplate
AI is very good for generating documentation
test generation refactoring of your code
but on the other hand when you need to use your logical thinking
you could use AI for architectural design
but again
what is the unique selling point in whatever you are building
so if you really want something very technical
one of the things you can look at is understanding the architecture
nurturing out outlining the architecture
how you want it to be and that's not it as well
design system is also very crucial when you leave it to AI
AI is gonna give you generic implementation
but again that product you're trying to build
needs to work with certain specification
that works with the problem
or the domain in which you're trying to solve that problem
some of these things are not something that AI can do for you
if you go the route of leaving it to AI to do for you
later in the project
you have to recustomize everything to solve the problem at hand
so this is very important that you know the role of the AI
from the beginning of the project
do your own part
use your part to engineer the AI to do something very powerful
and by so doing you reduce redundancy
and you enjoy working in collaboration with some of these machines